[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Nicolas Tenser bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté mon invitation
vous êtes spécialiste des questions
stratégiques professeur à Sciences Po on
vient d'en parler à l'instant après 10
mois de combat acharné quel épisode pour
la bataille de barmouth la ville de
l'est de l'Ukraine fait l'objet d'apre
combat mais aussi d'une guerre de
communication entre Russes et ukrainien
on en parlait à l'instant qu'est-ce que
cette bataille sanglante de bar mouth
dit de la guerre que nous observons
depuis plusieurs choses d'abord ça dit
beaucoup sur les intentions russes c'est
à dire non pas capturer une ville non
pas capturer un territoire pour faire
qu'il prospère mais anéantir
complètement la ville c'est ce qu'on a
vu déjà Mario Paul mais avant c'est ce
qu'on avait vu à grosnie c'est ce qu'on
avait vu à Alep c'est ce qu'on avait vu
partout où les Russes passent vraiment
chaque fois qu'il
s'empera s'emprunt de quelque chose
finalement il faut une sorte de désert
aujourd'hui c'est un même la nature a
été totalement détruite c'est vraiment
une destruction totale deuxièmement
c'est une bataille où les mercenaires de
Wagner et l'armée russe mais surtout les
mercenaires ont perdu sans doute environ
100000 hommes c'est-à-dire qu'on se dit
pour détruire un lieu qui n'était pas
totalement stratégique même si c'était
un point de passage mais quand même pas
stratégique à ce point vraiment on n'a
pas économisé les vies humaines du côté
russe la vie humaine pour eux non
strictement aucun sens troisièmement
c'est une sorte de victoire à la Pyrrhus
parce que aujourd'hui on a quand même
l'impression que le fait de contrôler
entre guillemets une grande partie de
farineur pour les Russes insidifie rien
on voit déjà l'armée ukrainienne qui
peut vraisemblablement commencer à
l'encercler ça va être en quelque sorte
j'allais dire l'impasse russe c'est une
sorte de lieu à partir duquel ils
pourront même plus progresser donc c'est
une victoire entre guillemets pour rien
une victoire désolée vous disiez il y a
déjà quelques mois nous ne pourrons pas
dire que nous ne savions pas que ça
n'était pas prévisible que cette
bataille de barmut n'était pas de notre
responsabilité oui c'est à dire que je
poste deux choses je pense d'abord que
bien sûr je suis de ceux qui considèrent
qu'il aurait fallu que nous intervenions
en Ukraine depuis 2014 je l'avais déjà
dit à cette époque je pense qu'il
fallait pardon intervenir c'est-à-dire
intervenir militairement c'est-à-dire
que on a laissé et pour ça aussi après
qu'il y a eu des accords de Minsk c'est
parce que les États-Unis déjà en 2013
qui avait refusé d'intervenir en Syrie
après les attaques chimiques contre la
Goutta donc les fameuses lignes rouges
de Baba n'ont jamais été appliquées en
2014 Audi finalement va aider l'Ukraine
peut-être petit à petit à se réarmer il
y a eu des opérations de modernisation
de l'armée ukrainienne mais mes rapports
déjà à ses offensives et à cette guerre
qui déjà avant 2002 avait causé quand
même 14000 victimes il n'y a eu aucune
intervention ce qui avait de conduit à
l'époque le chancelier l'agence de la
Merkel et le président Hollande à
s'engager dans les accords de risque
dont il savait parfaitement qu'il ne
mènerait nulle part que c'était une
manière de reculer pour mieux sauter et
puis après lorsque la guerre a été
déclarée de manière totale à partir du
24 février 2022 l'Occident a dit au
début mais qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on
va aider l'Ukraine on a aidé etc mais
chaque fois on a une sorte de de face
progressive on n'a pas tout de suite mis
le paquet aujourd'hui je me réjouis que
enfin la perspective de donner des FC S
et des missiles la plus longue portée
soit donnée à l'Ukraine qui est une
décision du président baiden et des
alliés mais cette décision là nous
étions quand même un certain nombre
depuis le début à dire il faut tout de
suite mettre le paquet si nous étions
intervenus je pense que nous aurions pu
sauver des dizaines de milliers de vie
sucrésiennes
on aurait oui mais qu'est-ce que
j'aurais véritablement changé c'est pas
pour ça que nous aurions eu des frappes
nucléaires sur Paris Londres ou
Washington je pense que le risque était
extrêmement faible je pense qu'en
revanche ça aurait vraiment mis un coup
d'arrêt à la Russie je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le risque est d'ailleurs
tout aussi élevé pour autant qu'il y ait
véritablement riz ça ne change rien mais
vous savez quand vous avez je dirais des
une armée étrangère et un régime surtout
prêt à tout
un moment il faut se décider le plus
vite possible vous avez évoqué les F-16
américains à l'instant au G7 ce weekend
Hiroshima au Japon Joe Biden a
effectivement ouvert pour la première
fois depuis le début du conflit et sur
demande répéter du président ski
l'éventualité de fournir à l'Ukraine ces
avions de combat non seulement des
formations de pilote mais aussi des
avions et c'est ça c'est en ça que c'est
un gamechanger comme on dit qu'est-ce
que précisément sur le terrain ça
pourrait changer pour les Ukrainiens ça
peut changer énormément d'abord
deuxièmement on sait que les avions
permettent tout simplement d'attaquer en
profondeur le dispositif ennemi c'est à
dire que la conjonction de char lourd à
l'offensive d'une capacité de frappe
dans la profondeur par les avions ou par
des missiles de plus longue portée ce
sont les composantes absolument
nécessaires couplées au renseignements
aériens bien sûr d'une offensive réussie
donc c'est ça qui change véritablement
tout je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a on a
besoin vraiment de donner à l'Ukraine
tous les moyens de gagner et bien sûr
les avions en font partie c'est trop
peur
alors si jamais trop tard c'est toujours
trop peu mais c'est bien qu'ils arrivent
maintenant c'est à dire que là on a
quand même on est quand même rassuré
mais effectivement pourquoi avoir
entendu si longtemps on voit par exemple
quand même des petits changements aussi
qui sont heureux vous voyez récemment
les déclarations de Jake Sullivan qui a
dit ce qui est une évidence mais les
armes américaines peuvent parfaitement
servir à frapper la Crimée au début vous
aviez une impression d'avoir une sorte
de ligne rouge du côté américain sur la
Crimée vous en avez toujours une mais
elle cédera bientôt sur pas de frappe
contre les objectifs militaires en
Russie même les Ukrainiens commencent à
le faire mais aujourd'hui vous savez
tout simplement même en vertu du droit
en vertu de l'article 51 de la Charte
des Nations Unies quand vous avez un
état qui est attaqué il peut se défendre
contre les objectifs militaires de cet
état que ce soit sur son sol ou sur le
territoire ennemi et tous ceux qui
l'aident sont parfaitement fondés à le
faire également le printemps touche
bientôt à sa fin dans un mois c'est
l'été c'est pas pour faire un point
saison mais c'est parce que la
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui était
promise annoncée en tout cas pour le
début du printemps se fait attendre
pourquoi quand savez-vous et est-ce
qu'on la verra effectivement entrer en
action lorsque personne ne le sait en
fait je crois à côté occidental et
j'allais dire si je le savais je ne
dirais pas mais je pense tout simplement
que aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore côté
ukrainien tout à fait suffisamment
d'armes même les F16 dont nous parlons à
l'instant ils sont prévus pour le début
de l'automne vraisemblablement donc ils
seront pas là donc on peut penser que
aujourd'hui il s'agit pour l'armée
ukrainienne de optimiser quand même les
pertes humaines lancer une offensive
alors que l'armée pourrait ne pas être
prête que l'ensemble du matériel n'est
pas arrivé même si quand même
aujourd'hui je crois que 80% environ des
chars promis sont bien arrivés à
destination ça n'aurait strictement
aucun sens donc il vaut mieux attendre
de toute manière les Russes eux ne sont
pas capables de lancer une offensive
donc aujourd'hui les Ukrainiens sont
capables de résister les Russes ne
peuvent rien faire l'offensive je pense
qu'elle viendra voilà au moment où
l'état-major ukrainien jugera qu'il a le
il a le plus de sens de réussir vous
pensez toujours que la Russie ne peut
pas gagner cette guerre non la Russie
alors ne soyons parfaitement la Russie
ne peut pas gagner cette guerre au sens
où elle n'a pas la possibilité de lancer
des offensives majeures elle peut en
revanche faire des dégâts elle en fait
en visant ce qu'elle fait depuis le
début des infrastructures civiles soit
d'abord des maisons d'habitation civils
des immeubles ou des marchés des écoles
des places publiques etc ou bien sûr des
infrastructures civiles elle peut
continuer à faire cela même si la
défense aérienne grâce à la livraison
notamment des patriotes mais d'autres
systèmes de défense devient de plus en
plus efficace mais il faut savoir que
tant que l'Ukraine n'aura pas récupéré
l'ensemble de son territoire je dis bien
l'ensemble y compris bien sûr la Crimée
il y a pas de raison de différencier la
crimes et du reste et bien ce sera
toujours une semi-victoire pour Poutine
ça il faut bien savoir c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui si l'Ukraine ne veut pas
récupérer tout son territoire Poutine
est encore gagnant parce qu'il imposera
le fait qu'il y a un certain nombre de
territoires qu'il a pu conserver et des
territoires occupés par les forces de la
Russie ça veut dire des tortures des
exécutions forcées des déportations
d'enfants je veux dire c'est ça la
réalité concrète sur le terrain pour la
population ukrainienne le retrait des
trop Prusse de l'ensemble du territoire
ukrainien c'est l'un des préalables à
une éventuelle signature d'une paix
posée par volodymerzilinski depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant dans son plan
de paix en 10 points dont on parle
régulièrement est-ce que vraiment ça
vous paraît réaliste oui ça me paraît
réaliste et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
au-delà des déclarations
imaginez que la Crimée demeure occupé
après un soi-disant accord de paix ça
voudrait dire que infinie la force paie
que le droit international c'est une
sorte de morceaux de papier qui n'a
strictement aucune valeur parce qu'en
droit international la Crimée est
ukrainienne elle n'est pas russe ça
voudrait dire aussi qu'on s'assoit sur
la déportation des Tatars de Crimée qui
a été de nouveau entreprise à partir de
2014 par Poutine les massacres les
disparitions forcées les exactions
contre aussi
toute la population qui qui vit de
manière terrible les spoliations parce
qu'il faut savoir que les Russes qui
installées en Crimée ont pour la plupart
voler des immeubles des biens qui
appartenaient à des Ukrainiens est-ce
que ça c'est tolérable et deuxièmement
est-ce qu'on peut inimaginer qu'il y ait
une négociation avec un régime qui a
commis de manière aussi massive et
répétée d'ailleurs depuis 23 ans
décrits massifs contre l'humanité je
veux dire lorsque aussi bien le
président Macron que Madame Colonna et
l'ensemble des dirigeants occidentaux
disent la justice c'est une condition de
la paix je pense qu'avant ils pouvaient
le dire peut-être de manière un peu
formelle aujourd'hui je pense qu'il le
pense et ça c'est une très bonne
évolution
pénale internationale une dernière
question le G7 a annoncé ce week-end de
nouvelles sanctions contre le Kremlin
notamment dans le secteur minier et
celui des diamants jusqu'ici il y a
énormément de sanctions prises contre le
Kremlin et les hauts dignitaires du
régime elles n'ont clairement pas permis
de d'arrêter la machine de elles sont
encore utiles ces sanctions il faut
aller encore plus loin alors
premièrement il faut aller plus loin
parce que quand même aujourd'hui
l'industrie de guerre russe quand même
souffre si j'ose dire et ça c'est une
bonne chose même si elle n'est pas
complètement atteinte donc il faut aller
plus loin il faut surtout aller plus
loin sur tout ce qu'on appelle les
sanctions secondaires il y a des
sanctions extraterritoriales qui
permettent de frapper des États ou des
groupes qui aident la Russie à sa
provisionner dans des composants qui
sont utiles pour son industrie qui
achètent son pétrole vous avez
aujourd'hui aussi bien l'Inde les
Emirats Arabes Unis la Chine sans parler
évidemment probablement de la Corée du
Nord qui aident la Russie vous avez
aussi eu des trafics vous avez eu
récemment une personnalité grecque qui a
été arrêtée en France qui va être sans
doute extradé aux États-Unis ce sera la
justice de le décider bien sûr parce que
cette personne fournissait des sommeil
conducteurs ou en tout cas étaient à la
tête d'un réseau de contrebande qui
fournissaient des semi-conducteurs à la
Russie donc là il faut vraiment frapper
il faut complètement assécher la Russie
il faut surtout cela j'ai insiste que
les sanctions soient maintenues à
l'avenir tant que les dommages de guerre
n'ont pas été payés tant que les
personnalités impliquées voilà non pas
été poursuivi merci beaucoup Nicolas
Tenzer d'être passé par le plateau de
Paris direct faire un point donc sur ce
conflit en
Ukraine et cette bataille de baroud dont
on parlait au début de notre entretien
merci encore on se retrouve nous juste
après la pause avec Damien coquet pour
la suite de Paris direct et on fera le
point notamment sur ces opérations de
démolition de bidonville à Mayotte à
tout de suite
[Musique]